ora o povo sol domingo é mais um vídeo
que é e onde vou ensinar como fazer um
choque grande com dois canos
isso foi uma sugestão várias pessoas nos
últimos vídeos e como vocês podem ver
equity para muito bem e desta vez justo
usar que os elásticos normais do
escritório e não aqueles las típicos das
pulseiras neste caso da cama elástica já
não dá pra usar porque não esticam
sintam tanto pelo menos os meus não
explicam que a primeira coisa que você
tem que fazer uma rifa caso você não
tenha percebido como fazer ela eu fiz um
vídeo há pouco tempo o mesmo ensinando a
fazer a rifa detalhadamente é porque
muitas pessoas pediram e achei cultural
ficou bom pelo menos as pessoas gostaram
e depois fazer a fifa tem largo foi a
volta de modo a fazer um tubinho alto
talvez não se deve fazer três tubinhos e
3g fãs e vão precisar fazer mais uma
pequena rifa que vão estar no final como
fazer
eu não tenho portanto vocês podem ficar
como eu estou por para que fique tudo
lisinho para não interferir com o
movimento dos elásticos de parte das
armas da arma que você não vê mais para
frente e vou começar por fazer ou
ficamos até da arma só colar um tubinho
outro usar cola e quinto mas vocês podem
usar outra coisa qualquer
nesse caso não vai fazer muita diferença
pois colares dois anos tem que juntar
duas rifas veja como é que eu estou
encaixar uma na outra e prendem com fita
é nem pressão pode ficar mais distinta
essa conexão
agora é só dar forma de crônica e é
bastante opcional e até fiz aquela
coisinha ali cúpula aí vai ficar
ligeiramente frente para não ficar
sempre a mesma crônica que eu uso para
minimizarmos e prendendo lhe mas só com
um pedaço de fita não ponho mais do que
isso porque se vocês quiserem muita fita
ali a distância entre a crônica é para
todos vocês vão puxar o objectivo vai
ficar muito grande então vai ficar
desconfortável para vocês agora está de
cortar um tubinho e está em 15º e contei
e os quadrinhos atacada quando ela
entende sentindo assim tenho certeza que
estou a dizer que as medidas certas
hoje colocou ele no meio dos dois
tubinhos e vejam que eu não gostei com o
dedo e não gostei de ver onde começa o
tubinho branco ok então vocês sobrepõe e
cortam medida certa vamos aportar mais 4
cm e vão colar ali quando acaba o tubo
verde nenhum tubman foi exatamente
quando acaba o fã assim muito um tento
de modo que fique pacífico à parte do
bilhete daquela aquela proteção proder
não sei como dizer que um animalzinho é
só colar com vocês deixarem que o bug
ball para não fazer muita atenção ainda
que o tubinho em que está preso então é
melhor vocês deixarem o imóvel para eu
ficar mais resistente com o tempo fui eu
que estou fazendo questão de risco é só
vocês fazerem um quadrado e não é tela
assim mas joguei mais clean do quiz e
depois é só ir lá como se fosse uma rifa
normal
agora muita atenção nesta partida rifa é
mais pequenina co
como é que vocês fizeram inicialmente
então o que vocês vão fazer um encaixe
dentro e vão largar assim geralmente
para que ela se desenrola e aumenta o
tamanho e aumentando o tamanho dentro da
fifa vai ficar um espaçamento e isso vai
permitir que vocês consigam espalmá-la é
incerto das partes quando vocês vão
vendo aqui mais para frente agora
começar de dobrar
assim na parte do maio 90 graus depois
do outro lado também
e aqui é o que no segmento onde ficou
entre as duas partes dobradas tem mais
ou menos uns intensa e aí depois vocês
vão a espalmar
as duas extremidades não fosse uma
reforma normal era um caso mais
complicado a cair
então se vocês fizerem desta maneira é
mais fácil que vocês podem usar uma
tesoura ou alguma coisa assim para
ajudar a deixar o acampamento melhor
nesta partida e agora é uma parte
bastante opcional vocês podem fazer o
design iguais de um lado e do outro e
chapéus na lateral dos elásticos mas
vocês quiserem tipo um design maior do
que o outro o que vai acontecer é que
vai ser um por cada vez como no caso nem
iguais vão ser os dois lados ao mesmo
tempo tirar essa parte que eu marquei
se vocês quiserem eu deixei uma
fotografia na fanpage é só ir lá e vem
ora como é que o design das partes das
fitas que eu vou pôr aqui agora é só
para dar um oi for só cair para não ser
levar aquela parte da lei do papel
shaq companheiro por isto que eu já fiz
vários protótipos e alguns novos então
os trabalhos
passado algum tempo a esta parte que a
gente gastou então é complicado é e
depois é só vocês aceitarem que jantarem
votarem por anormal como estava
agora é só encaixar nos dois canos e vai
lançar anda livremente a cair diz andar
podem continuar com o tutorial em ele
mostrou-me da fifa vai ficar resistente
e agora tem que dar esta forma que tem
um caso complicado explicar mas é
olhando para vocês acabaram de fazer em
ficar atirada para fora até que chega
para o último corta aqui uns e aí é só
ir fazer rir fazer é dar forma a rifa do
modo que vocês vão ver 40 anos para isso
basta para porque é pra fazer um gatilho
vocês podem ver que agora quando você
puxa o gatilho é aquela parte de cima
vai para trás e vai propor a rifa índice
em por agente foi em vão ser os
elásticos significado muito confuso mas
basicamente isso
nesta quarta usar só fita para aprender
mas se vocês quiserem podemos usar cola
e depois fita que vai ficar muito melhor
imagem sustenta que o sistema funciona
agora é só prender uma parte à outra do
brasil direto pra cima e agora é só
colar com bastante calma mesmo crime
depois encosta e depois disso vocês
podem pôr mais um capítulo por cima fica
melhor e já está aí e é isso já está
agora só falta mesmo por elástico de
disparar
inicialmente era para ser uma bastante
simples enquanto eu estava a fazer
o tutorial avaí más idéias todos então
eu decidi mudar e fazer de direito mais
complexos para conseguir destinar um
detido que foi preso ao espetáculo era
para ser uma coisa e que você encontra é
isso pessoal mesmo que o funcionamento
você não é bem bonita não sei que vocês
acham que é isso só temos o fim esperado
eo estado se vocês quiserem ajudar o
canal é só deixar um like e se inscreva
para acompanhar as coisas que eu faço e
claro que tiverem mais sugestões do
project e só deixaremos comentários e os
comentários mais votados ou mais vistos
aí que eu vou fazer então é isso muito
obrigado a próxima champions